rumors are swirling that queen elizabeth
ii may never live at buckingham palace
again but a source is telling e.t
not so fast
over the weekend reports surfaced that
the
year 95-year-old monarch who relocated
to windsor castle about 20 miles outside
of london when the pandemic hit in march
2020 is not expected to return to the
iconic london palace where she lived
with prince philip but e.t source
explains that's not the case
we are told the queen is continuing a
variety of engagements and official
duties at buckingham palace and stresses
that it will remain the central base of
the monarchy of course in 2016 a 460
million dollar decade-long refurbishment
project was announced and at the time it
was reported that the queen would remain
in the palace while the project was
underway
but et source says the queen and philip
moved into windsor during the lockdown
at the height of the pandemic to create
what was dubbed a covet-safe bubble
where prince philip lived until his
death last april and the source explains
that the renovations at buckingham
palace are expected to last until 2027.
meanwhile like millions of people hrh
has largely pivoted to video chats
she continues to hold her meetings with
prime minister boris johnson even while
she was fighting covet i have spoken to
senior palisades who assure me that the
queen is
in good spirits and she's suffering
cold-like symptoms i'm told that the
queen is at her desk she's doing light
duties she's reading her government
papers she's got her red boxes being
delivered to her daily so i think that's
all very encouraging
but on monday she held her first
in-person meeting since recovering from
kovid greeting canadian prime minister
justin trudeau in the windsor castle oak
room that's the queen rocking pearls a
blue patterned dress and flats next to
the 50-year-old politician who wore a
blue suit and purple tie and while the
palace won't comment on the record about
the subtle placement of blue and yellow
flowers in the background which many
think is a sign of support for the
ukrainian people amid russia's invasion
a source tells et quote very little
tends to happen by accident
[Music]